yeah welcome to new game 31 probably
probably you need to pronounce this in
some different way let's play it
straight away Kings Indian okay probably
the classical you get this so often yeah
okay okay so let's seem reform yeah a
form this is sound an interesting move
it can often be combined with the 91
Bishop e3 yeah exactly but now I'm
committed to this a five set up which is
not necessarily bad or something it's
just a particular way to defend this
this line but 93 it's a bit weird Bishop
e3 the normal way to proceed okay
interesting
so he will play before and probably a
5mm and what's quick am rook f6 g6 on
this other other maneuver before or
shouldn't should I on come on it's
probably a probably okay
yeah a5 is the the next move yeah should
I take or let him take all night c5
alternatively don't know okay let's
let's take them yeah night beef is a
puzzle move but okay on this I just
sacrifice I don't care on a five I it's
not even working I can sacrifice play c6
might be five fruit what i blundered
this the problem is not really the
material but it's a rock on the
eighth-ranked this is this is the big
issue
yeah okay the problem is really rookie
and I know queen bee eight in addition
this is this is the real issue otherwise
it's I don't know and I don't g4s is
something it's not entirely harmless
yeah okay queen bee eight I need to go
Quincy five and just hope that he
doesn't have a direct win
yeah Bishop c7
yeah there's certainly something some
way to to to win now now this this could
be one of them jeez fear I cannot play
g3 take care it's an exchange and is
having some young crap so I don't even
see a way to play for this slight trick
yeah maybe here and g3 but I can sure he
can just take the Queen completely Hey
okay should I resign this young maybe a
shorten yeah but resigning won't win
let's let's let's just a couple I mean I
lost so many um games like this on the
white side of the classical Kings Indian
we're like me here the black player
played like is brain dead and still
stuck so there was some attack and you
can lose the most winning positions it's
really possible sometimes okay right
here yeah it's a completely completely
over Bishop c8 and so on great
cannot even take them or maybe I can
okay I mean not not that it is great or
anything but I can play the move without
losing at the house instantly okay
then just I want I want one threat one
threat in this matter probably a white
knight reform wait wait wait wait maybe
last at least some ways to to screw up
let me not yeah it's not completely done
but I don't know it feels a bit shaky
what is doing the last couple moves
maybe Knight f6 h5 going for the
completely silly stuff
there are many pieces now in this in
this Fork really really many pieces
maybe irritate them yeah this is a pin
how do you protect your piece now I
can't believe this the game is still
going on and I wanted to resign time
ah very very strange yeah whatever
happens I I won't lose this this put
this game on the on position maybe I
will crap I was so busy playing quickly
i managed to our King edge six ago wow
what what technical play okay yeah wife
if you're down to three seconds you play
all kinds of nonsense but i'm pretty
sure if you give this to to the computer
i mean hey I was on minus 12 or
something this minus seven just ok it's
such good unbelievable sometimes about
f4 I mean it's still winning it can do
whatever you want but you really managed
to get all pieces in this in this
monster fork it's it's still winning and
yeah by now it's tricky and now a c5 is
basically the only the only way to save
himself and see for now is even better
for black but ok I was yeah I mean from
this position I was some content to this
is of course complete nonsense rook
air-five exchanges to a lost and came it
was just the time scramble stuff and now
for some reason he returned and unplayed
g32 to draw but ok it was just a matter
okay thanks for watching